joining us from our Washington bureau is
Elyse Foley politics and immigration
reporter for The Huffington Post Elyse
good morning good morning what are we
expecting on Tuesday do we have any idea
yet well there have been a lot of
reports last week that the president is
planning to end the program most likely
by making it so that these permits run
out so people have the permits for two
years that allows them to work legally
get driver's licenses live without some
level of fear of deportation and so what
is expected is that he will announce
that they can no longer renew those
which is functionally the same in terms
of their lives it's taking them away and
then we'll start to see people being put
back in this position so at least a very
long few days wait for some people out
there if this is rescinded what does it
mean for them at that time well if it is
that he doesn't allow them to renew they
won't necessarily lose their jobs
immediately but you'll start to see
people have them expire and so if you're
no longer allowed to work legally a lot
of these people are employed they'll
have to be fired by their employers
which includes some major companies
Microsoft has come out against this
because they employ some doctor
recipients so they will lose their
employment but they also will become at
risk of deportation and so even if the
Trump administration doesn't try to go
deport former daca recipients people who
come in contact with immigration and
customs enforcement do end up getting
detained even if they're not the people
being targeted so I think that if the
program ends you will see some people
who are former daca recipients being
detained and being deported at least we
reported in our first hour that the
president is actually facing pressure
from both sides of his own party on this
I mean there are there are states that
are threatening to sue if the program
isn't scrapped but there are GOP leaders
like Paul Ryan who are saying that it
should stay that's right so it's
something that he promised over and over
throughout his campaign talked about how
it was unconstitutional amnesty and
there were a lot of Republicans most
Republicans probably who feel the same
way who feel that President Obama never
should have done this at the same time
they also in this difficult political
position because deporting dreamers as
these people are called is not a popular
thing to do pulling even shows that
ending the program is often not a
popular thing to do even among
Republicans and so they are in this
position where perhaps it would be
easier for them to have the program
simply continue and then they wouldn't
have to try to pass anything and so you
have Paul Ryan you have even one of the
attorneys general who threatens Trump
with legal action saying that perhaps he
shouldn't do this and give them a chance
to pass some sort of legislation instead
if we did see some kind of legislation
what might that look like under this
Congress so there are a few different
options one of them is the DREAM Act
which is has been around for 16 years
they've never been able to get it
through both chambers but it would
provide a path to citizenship for many
of these people there's also a new bill
called the RAC act that has been
introduced in the house is going to be
introduced in the Senate that's their
framing is sort of a conservative
version of the DREAM Act it would also
provide a path to citizenship but for a
slightly narrower population and that
would probably have to be coupled with
some sort of other measures of border
security more money for immigration
enforcement perhaps money for the border
wall in order to get that through with
Republicans however they have not been
able to pass things like this before
they have not gotten them through both
chambers in the past so it would be a
very very much an uphill battle all
right Elyse Foley thank you thank you